Tổng thống mấy đơn đơn trang lại mùm só thông mùi một chà biết, ông Tinh Tượng,
Washington có thể đảnh đồng thuận với nhà và Trung Quốc trong việc cắt giảm bố khi ăn nhận.
Pháp biểu Trung Quốc họ về lãnh đạo năm nước Trung á tại nhà trắng,
tổng thống thuận đều só, phía nhấn hoá sẽ là một điều tịch với đồng thời trời biết,
đã thảo luận để vấn đề này với tổng thống nghe à lờ đi mì po chiến và chủ tịch Trung Quốc tập cận mình.
Theo ông, cả hai nhà lãnh đạo đều tỷ hiện mong muốn sạn một lực chức là những vực phục vụ vụ vư dân thay vì cho bố khi.
Phản nếu chứ tôi muốn này, người phân ngôn bộ ngoài ra Trung Quốc vào nên khẳng đình,
Mỹ cần đi đồng Trung Việt giảm mạnh khòa bố khi ăn nhấn của mình,
nhằm tạo điều kiện hướng tới mục tiêu sải trường hạn nhăn toàn dễ.
Bà nhấn mạnh, quy mô khòa bố khi của Trung Quốc không thể sâu sáng đợp với Mỹ và nghe,
sâu đó yêu cơ bắt kinh tham gia đam phán kịm sát bố khi ở dưới này là không hợp lý.